welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and frozen to released a new
trailer that reveals the major plot
details both obvious elements through a
bedtime story and easier to miss ones
through background visuals and the
amount of fear and Olaf sighs I'm gonna
break down this trailer shot by shot for
all the interesting clues that you might
have overlooked let's get started
far away as north as we can go once
stood an enchanted forest
you see an enchanted forest yes it was a
magical place okay this opening clip is
a flashback tour a bedtime story told to
young Elsa and Anna by their father the
leaked King Agner and their mother Queen
Doudna who died in a set it's shipwreck
ever in the first frozen Agner explains
that to the far north of arendelle was
once an enchanted forest populated by
this community of people who we now know
is the north old rrah and among them are
practitioners of magic including this
girl who it seems could be a young Adana
and an R as a boy saw her using her wind
powers believes we've been wondering
what these four symbols that have
appeared on all the ice crystals and the
Stonehenge II boulders mean and now it
appears that they reflect the four
natural elements earth air water fire in
the way that Elsa can manipulate water
particles to conjure ice it appears that
this girl can control air to conjure
wind explain more how this might work
out as we go let's move on but something
went wrong since then no one can get in
or out
papa that was epic
okay a ganar story continues describing
war that broke out between the forces of
arendelle and the north older tribe
among these arendelle soldiers is this
big fella this could be Agnes father
King rune eared rune eared Rooney hard
but then this pink flame spreads
throughout the forest soldiers on both
sides also blasted with a powerful wind
it appears that these natural forces
attack both warring factions of humans
kind of like mother earth shoving the
two fighting kids in opposite corners
no one gets ice cream now and this wall
of fog blocks off the symbol boulders
closing off the enchanted forest perhaps
this enchanted forest was previously
like a shared territory between sides
with everyone being able to partake in
its Garden of Eden esque splendor and
bountiful natural resources but then
when a turf war broke out nature blocked
it off trapping some of them inside but
leaving out everyone else including
Agner in the Doudna who you'll notice
gives a sad little long full expression
at the end of the story she leaves a
room and if you think about it this
natural blockade might be why arendelle
is now so dependent on trade with
foreign nations which results in Ag
Nerina doing his death let's see the
SATA super kefir and the whole drama
with Hans and the Southern Isles in the
first movie it's a classic tale of when
you fight over cereal with your sister
you force your parents to have to drive
to the store to buy more cereal and then
terrible things happen to them that is
on you munna what would I do without you
you'll always have me
[Music]
how's Elsa seemed weird to you she seems
like Elsa
there's just voice voice what does that
mean okay you might recognize the piano
music here this track is called above
and beyond it's actually featured in the
trailer for the live-action Cinderella
film at 2015
[Music]
and the sisters comfort each other and
actually in the frozen tube footage
shown at d23 Ayane sings a lullaby here
to Elsa
it's the folk song that their mother
sang with them as kids which includes
the lyric where the north wind meets the
sea there's a river full of memory could
be foreshadowing the river that uh
Nanoha float down the other shot in the
northern enchanted forest here on a
teller sister you'll always have me
which could be a clue for the central
conflict of this film
Elsa answering a call to leave to the
forest perhaps even permanently since
you know someone with dangerous ice
magic powers probably shouldn't live in
society like I don't know if you know
this but when Elsa sneezes little booger
icicles fly out and stab you in the eye
also waking up as part of another
musical sequence run at d23 a song
called into the unknown in which the
mysterious voice that distracted her
before calls to her again
now she sings back to it and then the
sequence uses her magic to conjure icy
forms and the melody of this song itself
echoes the voices call
into the give me an Oscar look I'm sorry
I'm just trying to enjoy this new single
as much as possible before my niece's
play it over and over and over again as
holiday season into the next clip
the kingdom is not safe okay after Elsa
sings a song or maybe because she sings
that song and that high note just pisses
everything off various natural forces
assault arendelle the pink flames snuffs
out all the lamps and lanterns powerful
winds blow through the streets drag Sven
out of his stable even the earth beneath
their feet crumbles as the cobblestones
kick up in this trimmer the people of
arendelle flee the city to the cliffs
where presumably the trolls offer them
some safety there's a shot several of
them looking outward in shock glutton
oaken owner of wandering oaken's trading
post in sauna now perhaps these people
are watching arendelle collapse into
ruin victim to the four natural forces
attacking in the same way the warring
soldiers were attacked by nature Elsa as
a waterbender could be the target as a
magical person away from the tome Scooby
nature's way of draggin her back moving
on find who he's calling to you they may
have answers I'm going with you Anna no
excuse me I climb to the North Mountain
survived a frozen heart and saved you
from my ex-boyfriend so you know I'm
coming normal
okay here the troll leader granpabbie
explains else's journey with visions
depicting a bridge actually a similar
bridge shows up later in this trailer
that could be part of the pathway
between Aaron DOE and the enchanted
forest
there's also depictions of a truce
between arendelle's forces in the north
old rafale by armed conflict maybe the
fact that this war ended without ever
being settled just nature forcing a
wedge between both sides it could now be
on Elsa to return to this place and
literally clear the air this leads to
Elsa joined by Anna Kristoff Sven and
Olaf to journey northward you can see
Elsa's old ice castle and Olaf literally
sleep walking behind Elsa it's also a
word carved into the tree beside her
this could be a way past travelers found
their way back to the forest gateway and
when they arrive at the wall of fog as
else's hand reaches out into the fog
tiny crystals illuminate within it you
think about it fog mist it's a form of
water vapor so Elsa has one who can
manipulate these water particles
probably uses those magical abilities in
order to bend those particles and clear
paths and you know not to get too dark
but just imagine what someone like this
could do to the water particles in your
blood you know we're talking Magneto and
x2 here just don't mess with her next
clip where are we how did you get in the
force the mist parted for as impossible
where did you learn magic on the other
side of this fog the group runs into the
north ultra as well as some soldiers
from arendelle these soldiers are led by
Lieutenant Matthias or Matthias boy
spice sterling K Brown now notice how
many of them appear to be older
these soldiers might have been the ones
who got trapped in the enchanted forest
when this war was paused by Nature Osumi
Yelena the leader of the North Aldrich
is voiced by Martha Plimpton and other
North ultra people honey meirin voiced
by Rachel Matthews and writer voiced by
Jason Ritter now there's a theory that
Christoph might have also been part of
the North ultra maybe even Molina could
be his mother
even the tribes connection to the
reindeer and Christoph's unexplained
connection to the trolls and Christoph's
mother being an unknown part of his
backstory there's also a shot of Elsa
using her magic to hop across these
beams kind of like Peter Parker Venice
and she's wearing the same outfit that
she wore in that beach scene we've seen
lots of footage of seems as though a
major part of her journey will be a
trial that tests her magical abilities
but more on that and the rest of this
trailer then don't run into fire
[Music]
okay here on an Olaf paddle and ice
canoe down a river uses one of Olas arms
as a paddle and they float past these
sleeping rock giants presumably the same
ones who come alive later
now speculated in the past these could
be inspired by the yoke nor Giants of
Norse mythology if I mispronounce that
which I probably did in some way
apologize the giant boulders and rock
surfaces across Norway's landscape were
once believed to have been made by these
giants or be the sleeping giants
themselves it's also shot up also with
this salamander now this little guys
named Bruni and noticed the pattern on
its back I'm wondering if Bruni could be
the source of that pink flame which in
past footage seems to emanate from a
small creature that hops from tree to
tree if this is true it's possible that
each of these four natural forces could
be embodied in natural spirits fire in
this little guy water slash ice in the
horse spirit the nock earth and the rock
Giants and Arab / wind in the leaves or
the trees that might be the reason that
when this tornado engulfs the group most
of the autumn leaves on the surrounding
tree branches and on the ground do not
get blown away as well
like folks if wind is strong enough to
blow away a reindeer it's strong enough
to blow every nearby dead leaf off the
ground unless those leaves are not dead
they're still alive in sentience and
they scream when you break them moving
up magic is very alluring without you
see they use herself protect arendelle
at all costs
[Music]
I believe in you Elsa
okay in this clip we see some shots of
Elsa in the song sequence into the na
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'll stop I promise
Sven runs alongside the pack of other
reindeer on a field which dissolves into
a young reindeer in the arms of I think
that's young a Doudna there now I don't
know if this would be spin necessarily
reindeer Bucks tend to live ten years
unless you're a still believing child
and Rudolph lives forever and I think
it's been a lot longer than 10 years
since young doing a grew older passed
away and then Elsa and Anna grew older
then we see the rock giants attacking
and we return to this footage of Elsa in
the crashing waves with the NOK horse
spirit she does this awesome move
somersaulting underwater conjuring the
snowflake to block it and then its
hooves are holding her down and she
grabs them and crystallizes them it
seems like part of Elsa's trial is to
tame this horse
maybe her running repeatedly out into
the waves which previously seemed like
behavior of an insane person all might
be to confront the NOK and wrestle it
into submission because if she is a true
waterbender
I also shouldn't have any problems of
waves right unless they're being
controlled by the water horse spirit the
NOK in which case retaining the NOK
could reflect her own gaining full
control over her powers becoming one
with herself
and moving on to the final clip
quick question is the hole putting us in
mortal danger gonna be a regular thing
okay so Elsa swings up on Abba knock
with harness and then a rock giant rises
appearing to lift an entire mountain
range with it yikes
and after the title card the trailer
closes with a tag featuring Olaf
initially oblivious as various natural
forces tried to kill him sound until he
sees the knock underneath his own
reflection does he scream and terror in
flee now if you look further down the
water's edge there's a boulder with a
circular pattern on its surface its
reflection in the water kind of makes
that look like a set of eyes almost for
me in a face as if this Boulder had to
rise up as a rock giant and tried to
crush him it smells like Mother Nature
watched the first frozen and some of
those frozen shorts and just found Olaf
super annoying so now she's deploying
her forces to murder him out of the
movie I get it he's a he's a bit much
comment down below with your thoughts on
this new trailer hit that like button
and subscribe to new rock stars for
breakdowns of everything you love follow
me on instagram twitter at da vas and
thank you for watching and away from
this blue dungeon and into I know I said
I'd stop at the rule of threes demands
it beyond
[Music]